[संगीत]
हेलो गुड इवनिंग एवरीवन तो वेलकम टू डे 16
ऑफ दिस बेस्ट मास्टरी कोर्स एंड सबसे पहले
आप मुझे ये बता द सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है
नहीं आ रही उसके बाद फरदर हम आगे
बढ़ेंगे और देर इ ओनली वन पर्सन लाइव आज
तो मैच नहीं था यार कल हो गया
मैच
[संगीत]
ओके थैंक यू तो आज हम पढ़ने वाले पहले जो
प्रीवियस टॉपिक हमने पढ़ा था किसे
रिलेटेड आई थिंक रिमेंबर ट स टॉपिक
वाज गेट इट गेट इट वन
फस्ट
ओके जो प्रवेश टॉपिक था हमने केस से
रिलेटेड पढ़ था केस स्टेटमेंट के बारे में
पढ़ा था केस और इ स्टेटमेंट के बारे में
पढ़ा था तो मैंने इ स्टेटमेंट को भी आपको
डिटेल में पढ़ाया था और के स्टेटमेंट के
बारे में बताया था तो यह जो कंडीशन है
कैसे हम यूज करते हैं और मैंने य भी बताया
था कि जो केस स्टेटमेंट है वो पूरी तरह
रिप्लेसमेंट नहीं है स्टेटमेंट का लेकिन
काफी सिनेरियो होंगे आपके जहां पर के
स्टेटमेंट इ बेटर देन द इ स्टेटमेंट
क्योंकि इजी है मैनेज करना ज्यादा से
ज्यादा इफ एफ स्टेटमेंट देने की बजाय हम
क्या करेंगे के स्टेटमेंट का यूज कर सकते
हैं और वो भी क्या एक वेरिएबल के बेस पर
क्या करती है आपके वैल्यू को डिसाइड करती
है आपके केसेस को डिसाइड करती है तो आज
मैं एक काम करता हूं सबसे पहले आगे बढ़ने
से पहले मैं क्या करने वाला हूं ना आपको
एक एग्जांपल के साथ समझाने चाहता हूं और
भी केस के बारे में कि केस स्टेटमेंट का
थोड़ा सा एक एग्जांपल के साथ ताकि आपको और
ज्यादा अच्छे से क्लियर मिल जाए क्लेरिटी
मिल जाए एक एग्जांपल के साथ हम पढ़ेंगे
इसमें के स्टेटमेंट के बारे में नेक्स्ट
जो आज हम टॉपिक पढ़ने वाले हैं वह हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं वाइल लूप के बारे में और
वाल लप में भी एक इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है अ
गेट ओटी ओटीएस कमांड है वह कैसे हम यूज़
करते हैं और आज काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन है
आप लोगों के लिए क्योंकि जो चीज आप पढ़ने
वाले हो ना व इतनी इंटरेस्टेड है नॉर्मली
क्या है कि जो रियल लाइफ में आप टूल्स
देखते हो कैसे व ऑप्शंस यूज करते हो तो आज
व वो ऑप्शंस आप खुद से डिसाइड कर पाओगे आज
वो सिखाने वाला हूं आपको तो चलिए हम चलते
हैं पहले जो हमारा आज का एक एग्जांपल के
साथ हम जाने वाले हैं कि मैं एक स्क्रिप्ट
बनाना चाहता हूं मैं एक स्क्रिप्ट बनाऊंगा
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम क्या रहेगा सिटी चेकर ड
एसए सिटी चेकर ड एएच मतलब क्या है कि मेरे
पास ना लिस्ट ऑफ सिटीज है और मैं उसके
बेसिस पर क्या करना एक छोटी सी स्क्रिप्ट
बनाना चाहता हूं कि जैसे मैं सिटी को चूज
करूंगा ना उस सिटी का तो कंट्री का नाम
पता चलता है कि वो सिटी किस कंट्री में है
क्योंकि सभी का सिटीज की कंट्रीज का हमें
मालूम नहीं होता तो हम एक छोटी सी बनाना
चाहते हैं आप चाहो तो कितनी भी बड़ी बना
सकते हो तो मैं इसके लिए मैंने पहले से ही
क्या कर रखा है कि एक टी एक्सटी फाइल है
मेरे पास सटी डटी इसके अंदर मैंने मैं
आपको दिखाऊ कटी ट एटर यहां पर टोक्यो लंडन
लॉस एंजल्स मॉस्को दुबई मैनचेस्टर
न्यूयॉर्क पेरिस बेंगलोर यह सारी सिटीज का
नाम मैंने यहां पर मेंशन किया हुआ है इनके
बेसिस पर हम क्या करेंगे अपनी एक
स्क्रिप्ट रेडी करेंगे एक स्क्रिप्ट
बनाएंगे एक
ओके
एक स्क्रिप्ट हम रेडी करने वाले हैं तो व
मल्टी एक रियलिस्टिक आपको स्क्रिप्ट लगेगी
हां कैसे काम कर रही है और आपको क्या आदत
भी पड़ रही है धीरे धीरे आप स्क्रिप्ट को
कैसे बनाओगे तो मैं आपको दिखाता हूं आप
स्क्रिप्ट को कैसे बनाओगे फ एग्जांपल मैं
चलता हूं एक ननो
न ननो सीटीटी एक्स हो सीटी एस करता हूं
मैं इ एटर देन मैं क्या करता हूं स्ल बिन
स्ल बस क्योंकि हमें ये मेंशन कर रहे हैं
आप कौन सी बैंक लाइन बस नेक्स्ट अब मुझे
क्या करना है मुझे पहले तो चैलेंज य है कि
जो लिस्ट ऑफ सिटीज मैंने आपके सामने मेंशन
की है वो जो लिस्ट ऑफ सिटीज आपके सामने
मेंशन की है ना उसको मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं देखो यूजर्स को नहीं पता ना कि मैं इस
स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर कौन सी सीटी अवेलेबल है
तो मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं ऑप्शन देना
चाहता हूं कि हां भैया यह य स्क्रिप्ट इन
सिटीज के बारे में है और आपको पता चल
जाएगा आपको पता चल जाएगा कि जि इस ऑप्शन
को सेलेक्ट कीजिए इस सिटी के अकॉर्डिंग
अगर आप पता चना चाते ये सिटी किस कंट्री
के अंदर है तो आप पता कर सकते हो कैसे तो
मैं सबसे पहले क्या करना पड़ेगा मुझे
ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड करने के अगर मैंने यूजर्स
को ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड करने है चूज करने के
लिए तो ओबवियसली मुझे क्या करना पड़ा
सेलेक्ट कमांड को यूज करना पड़ेगा तो ओके
सेलेक्ट कमांड मैं यूज करने वाला
हूं सेलेक्ट कमांड देन उसके बाद मैं एक
वेरिएबल क्रिएट करना चाहता हूं सीटी एक
वेरिएबल मैंने क्रिएट किया ज्यादा हो गया
ओके सीटी देन इन एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट किया
सीटी देन अब मैं क्या करना वो लिस्ट है
मेरे पास लिस्ट ऑफ कमांड है ना उसको यूज
करने वाला हूं और मैं उसको कॉपी इसके अंदर
कैसे करूंगा तो प्रॉब्लम ट उसको कॉपी नहीं
कर पाऊंगा तो मैं एक बार करता हूं इसको
कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक करता हूं इधर ही
इसको अपने एक बार काली के टर्मिनल ओपन
करता हूं वहा पर मेरे लिए क्या इजी हो
जाएगा सारी चीजों को मैनेज
करना इी हो जाएगा मेरे लिए ताकि मैं कट
कॉपी पेस्ट कर
पा
चलो नेक्स्ट
मैं यहां पर क्या करता हूं आपको लिए जूम
कर देता
हूं आपको दिख रहा ओके अभी मैं क्या करता
हूं एक
बार दोट में ओपन कर लेता हूं य भी मैं जूम
कर देता आपके सामने ये रहा गुड
नेक्स्ट ये रहा यहां पर क्या करता हूं मैं
कैट करता हूं सटी एकटी मेरे पास सीटी है य
य इन सबको मैं क्या कर रहा हूं कॉपी कर
लेता हूं इन सब को मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
कॉपी कॉपी सिलेक्शन देन गो टू माय एलएस
करता हूं नो सटी ड एसए है मेरे पास तो मैं
नो करता हूं सटी ड एसए के अंदर जाता हूं
फिर से डट
एसए ओके तो अभी मैं यहां पर था और यहां पर
मैं क्या करना ओके चलो लैक सिटी कर रहा
हूं देन इन इन के बाद मैं क्या मेंशन करने
वाला हूं ये रहा अपनी लिस्ट ऑफ सिटीज ये
रहा कंट्रोल शिफ्ट v तो मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं देखो अभी मैंने यहां पर ऑप्शंस
दिए कि मैं कौन सी सिटी सेलेक्ट करना
चाहता हूं सिलेक्ट सिटी एक तो मेरी टोक्यो
है स एंजल्स है ये अगर मेरी स्पेस
सेपरेटेड सीटी है तो मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा उसको डबल कोट के अंदर प्रोवाइड
करना ताकि कोटिंग ना हो वर्ड स्लिटिंग ना
हो उसके बाद मस्को दुबई मैनचेस्टर उसके
बाद न्यूयॉर्क ये है अब मैं आगे आगे बढ़ते
हैं देखो ये रहा बेंगलोर ये सारी
इस्तानबुल मिलन अबू दबी ये सारी है और
जैसे ही मुझे क्या आपको पता है सेलेक्ट
कमांड को हम कैसे यूज करते हैं तो यहां तक
मैं ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड करना चाहता हूं यहां
तक मैंने ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड कर दिया अब जब
मैंने जो लिस्ट ऑफ ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड करने के
बाद जितने भी ऑप्शन थे मैंने मेंशन कर दिए
उसके बाद मैं क्या करूंगा मुझे बताना कि
भैया मेरे यहीं तक ऑप्शन थे जो यूजर को शो
करने हैं उसको बताने के लिए मैं क्या
सेमीकलन यूज करूंगा देन उसके बाद मैं क्या
यूज करूंगा डू सेलेक्ट कमांड के साथ तो
मैं डू यूज करता हूं ना नेक्स्ट अब आपको
पता है सेलेक्ट कमांड के साथ मैंने ओपन ये
कर लिया उसके बाद क्या है सेलेक्ट कमांड
को अगर मुझे क्लोज करना हो तो मैं क्या
करता हूं डन डन करता हूं ना ओके अब मैंने
इसमें क्या है ये स्लेक कमांड को क्लोज कर
लिया अब मैं क्या करना फर्दा चाहता हूं कि
अब मैं इन ऑप्शंस के बेस
अपने केस सेट अप करूंगा कि अगर मैं टोक्यो
सेलेक्ट करूं तो मुझे पता चल जाए कि कौन
सी कंट्री में लंदन सेलेक्ट करूं तो कौन
सी कंट्री में है न्यूयॉर्क सिलेक्ट करू
तो कौन सी कंट्री में है तो वो सब किसके
अंदर करना पड़ेगा वो सारे एक्शन मुझे
किसके अंदर परफॉर्म करने पड़े इसके अंदर
सेलेक्ट कमांड के अंदर अब वो एक्शन
परफॉर्म करने के लिए मुझे क्या करना होगा
मुझे केस स्टेटमेंट का यूज करना होगा मैं
चाह तो इ स्टेटमेंट का भी यूज कर सकता हूं
अब इफ क्या क्या एफ देन एफ देन करते करते
आप पागल हो जाओगे मेरी क्या है केस
स्टेटमेंट है तो मैं क्या करूंगा केस देन
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं यहां पर डबल
कोड और आपको मैंने दो चीजें बताई थी
इंपोर्टेंट एक तो डबल कोट है ब स्प्लिटिंग
से बचाने के लिए एक आप यूज करोगे डॉलर
सिंबल क्योंकि डॉलर सिंबल क्यों यूज करने
वाले हो य कि जो ये पैरामीटर है पैरामीटर
की वैल्यू को यहां पर इसी के बेस पर आप
क्या करना चाहते हो आप इन्वेस्टिगेट करना
चाहते हो इसी के बेस प केस कैलकुलेट करना
चाहते हो तो सीटी इन देन हम क्या करें इट
एंटर उसके बाद चलते हैं अब इसके बेस पर हम
केस डिफाइन करेंगे अब फॉर एग्जांपल अब
मेरा अगर टोक्यो आता है फॉर एग्जांपल मेरा
टोक्यो आता है इसके अंदर तो मैं कैसे
टोक्यो टी ओ के वाई टोक्यो अब इस अब मेरा
क्या पहला केस ही है टोक्यो अगर आया तो
उसके बाद क्या है केस जब एक बार डिफाइन कर
दिया मैंने उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है
इसके बाद क्लोज ब्रैकेट क्लोज ब्रैकेट
लगानी है देन उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है
आपको पता है कि उसके बाद स्पेस और वो
कंडीशन लिखनी है जो इसके साथ मैं परफॉर्म
करना चाहता हूं कौन सी कंडी परफॉर्म करना
चाहता हूं इसकी कंट्री कंट्री वो करना
चाहता हूं तो मैं सीओ कंट्री कंट्री बताना
चाहता हूं तो कंट्री इक्वल टू किस कंट्री
में ये हमरा जापान में देन कंट्री इक्वल
टू और जापान देन उसके बाद मैंने इसको क्या
क्लोज करना है अब इसका क्या काम ये इतनी
कमांड थी तो डबल कॉलन नेक्स्ट लाइन में हम
चलते हैं नेक्स्ट केस क्या है मेरा नेक
केस मेरा क्या है लंदन अब कुछ ऐसी कंट्रीज
भी है
जो दो कंट्रीज है और एक ही सिटी में है तो
फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैं लंदन है और लंदन और
मैनचेस्टर दोनों के दोनों क्या है एक ही
कंट्री के अंदर यूनाइटेड किंगडम अगर मुझे
यहां पर ऐसे करना है कि दो दोनों जो सिटी
है एक ही उसके अंदर है कंट्री के अंदर तो
मैं य पर क्या कर सकता हूं मल्टीपल ऑप्शन
भी दे सकता हूं मल्टीपल केसेस भी दे सकता
हूं कि अगर हा जो यहा परने केस डिा में से
कोई भी एक मिलेगा तो यह टास्क आपको एकसे
परफॉम लंदन उसके बाद पाइप सिंबल यज करूंगा
देन मानचे एम ए एन सी एच मैनचेस्टर देन
उसके
क्या के स्टेटमेंट इतना केस य है अभी
इसमें अगर लंदन अगर इस इस केस में जो सिटी
है य पर लंदन सेलेक्ट किया ने तो भी इसका
यह
जो एक्शन है वो परफॉर्म होगा अगर
मैनचेस्टर तब भी एक्शन परफॉर्म होगा अभी
क्या है मैं फिर से मैं क्या
कंट्री यू ओके कंट्री करना
था ओ यू एनटी आर वाई
कंट्री टी आरवा कंट्री देन इक्वल अब ये
किसके अंदर है यूनाइटेड किंगडम यूनाइटेड
किंगडम
यूनाइटेड किंगडम यूनाइटेड किंगडम के अंदर
देन उसके बाद डबल ये उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
मेरा जो केस है नेक्स्ट केस में मेरा क्या
रहेगा नेक्स्ट केस में मेरा क्या है
की लॉस एंजल्स एंड न्यू र्क दोनों के
दोनों क्या है लॉस एंजल्स और जो मेरा
न्यूयॉर्क है वो एक ही उसके अंदर है तो
मैं क्या लिखा लॉस एंजल्स
लॉस एंजल्स उसके बाद नेक्स्ट पाइप सिंबल
और पाइ सिंबल के बाद क्या न्यूयॉर्क दोनों
दोनों एक ही सिटी के अंदर है न्यू
योर्क यही सिटी के अंदर उसके बाद चलो एक
ही कंट्री के अंदर
है
कंट्री देन इसके बाद कौन सी कंट्री के
अंदर है मेरा यूएस के अंदर ओनली यूनाइटेड
स्टेट्स सिपली देन मैं क्या करने वाला
इसके बाद य है मेंशन करने वा हूं यूएस
मेंशन कर देता हूं यूएस नेक्स्ट सिंपली
नेक्स्ट चलते हैं हम उसके बाद नेक्स्ट केस
हम डिफाइन करते हैं नेक डिफाइन करने के
लिए
मस्को मोस्को मोस्को ऐसे मेंशन करेंगे देन
इसके बाद क्लोज किया उसके बाद हम क्या
कंट्री का
नाम कंट्री इक्वल उसके बाद डबल कोर्ट ये
देन डबल कोट के अर मोस्को किसके अंदर
रशिया रशिया चलो इसके बाद नेक्स्ट केस में
अगर आपको क्या करनाना अगर चाहो तो आप अगर
आपको अच्छा दिखे मतलब ऐसे कंफ्यूज ना हो
तो आप एक काम कर सकते हैं अगर आपको कमेंट
में मेंशन करना था तो चलो कमेंट के बेस पर
हम कर सकते ताकि आपको इजी हो जाए तो य पर
कमेंट मेंशन कर दिया
केस केस वन मेंशन कर दिया मेरा कमेंट के
अंदर ताकि आपको और भी अच्छे से दिखे ओके
नेक्स्ट यह
रहा के बाद है मेरा
केस केस टू मेरा यह है मेरा नेक्स्ट उसके
बाद मेरा है केस य है चलो इस तरीके से केस
थ इस तरीके से केस थ है मेरे पास नेक्स्ट
अब मैं क्या करने वाला हूं केस फोर कल के
के नो नोन
नो चलो य पर क्या है केस
फ
य पर क्या है केस फोर मैं य क्या मेंशन
करने वाला केस फ केस फ मस्को किस कंट्री
में रशिया के अंदर नेक्स्ट ताक अभी क्या
है आपको क्लियर क्लेरिटी मिल जाए थोड़ा अब
मैं कौन सा अगला यूज करने वाला हूं केस फ
इस तरीके से केस फ केस फ के अंदर फर एपल
मेरा क्या है मोस्को के बाद में यूज कर
रहा हूं दुबई मैं क्या करहा दुबई डी
यू बी ए आई दुबई देन उसके बाद ये रहा दुबई
बाद कंट्री का नाम
है कंट्री इक्वल टू दुबई किस कंट्री में
है आपको पता होगा य यूनाइटेड अरब स्टेट
यूएई हम क्या यहां पर लिख देता हूं यूएई
यूएई तो ये रहा डबल कोट यह रहा देन देन
देन ये रहा यूएई चलो अब एक और चीज है दुबई
के साथ एक और कंट्री है जो एक यूएई के
अंदर है व कौन सी है इसका नाम है आपके पास
है अबू धाबी आपके पास है अबू दबी ए बी यू
दाबी डी एच ए बी आई ओके अबुदा भी य भी इसी
कंट्री के अंदर है नेक्स्ट अब बात करते
हैं हम चलते हैं इस इसी अगला केस केस
सिक्स हम मेंशन करने वाला
चलो केस सिक्स केस सिक्स में क्या क्या
मेरा केस सि मेंशन करना ह दुबई के बाद
मेरा आ गया
पेरिस पी ए पेरिस देन यरा पेरिस किसके
अंदर
है
पेरिस मेरा कंट्री इक्वल मैंने क्या पेरिस
मे किसके अंदर फ्रांस के अंदर ये क्या है
फ्रांस के
अंदर फ्रांस ओके ये क्या है मेरा फ्रांस
के अंदर है इस तरीके से क्या कर सकता हूं
मैं सभी केसेस को डिफाइन करता हूं इट विल
टेक टाइम मैं चाहूं तो अगर एक काम करता
हूं आपका टाइम वेस्ट ना हो मैं एक फाइल से
उठा लेता हूं इनको इसको मेरे पास है इसका
सिटी चेकर देन
चलो कहां तक क्या पेरिस चलो बट इसका कट
कॉपी पेस्ट का ये रहा यहां तक हम उठा लेता
क्योंकि सारी चीजें वही है कॉपी और मैं
क्या करता आपको
सिंपली सिंपली य र हम चलते हैं इधर यहां
पर टैब यहां पर कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व ये रहा
सारे केस य पर मेंशन हो गए अब मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं सिंपली य चलता हूं आपके सामने
देखने को मिल रहा है पेरिस हो गया पेरिस
के बाद क्या बेंगलोर बेंगलोर का क्या है
केस नेस्ट नेक्स्ट केस इसका केस
सिक्स केस सि केस सेन केस से नेक्स्ट बलर
हो गया ओके इन्होने क्या अलग अलग मैंने
मेंशन कर रखा इसमें नो इशू मैं इसको क्या
कर देता
हूं थोड़ा अरेंज कर देता आपके लिए
बस सिंपली य रहा देन आपके लिए क्या है
यह य रहा
नेक्स्ट चलो और ये
रहा
यहां पर क्या
केस केस हो गया आपके सामने यह रहा अब यहां
पर मैं क्या कर इसको अरेंज कर देता
हूं ताक थोड़ा सा अच्छा लगे
आपको उसके बाद ये रहा
केस नान इसका केस नाइन है देन यह मेरे पास
आ जाएगा
इटली यर चलो
य रहा केस केस 10 मेरा उसके बाद मेरा
लास्ट इटली के बाद यह
रहा कंट्री
केनिया
कंट्री नेक्स्ट है
मेरा केस 11 मेरे पास केस 11 और आई मुझे
लगता है थोड़ा सा इसको कर देता
हूं थोड़ा अच्छा दिखे आपको भी उसके बाद
मेरे पास केस 11 हो गया देन बर्लिन मतलब
बहुत सारे हैं काफी ज्यादा टाइप करने में
टाइम लगता है हमें बेस्ट ऑप्शन यह है कि
मैंने लिखा हुआ था पहले से ही तो इसको मैं
क्या कर देता हूं आपके सामने चटर य
रहा केस 12 देन देखो कितने केस हमने इसके
साथ मेंशन कर दिया अगर ये इफ कंडीशन के
साथ आप लग जाते ना तो आपकी हालत खराब हो
जाती है इसको टाइप कर उसको करते करते इ इफ
देन इफ देन अलिफ देन अलिफ देन लगाते लगाते
आपकी क्या है हालत खराब होने वाली थी भैया
तो अब चलते हैं चलो
नेक्स्ट केस 13 केस 13 उसके बाद नेक्स्ट
चल रहे हैं हम ये रहा फि से चलो चलो चलो
कंट्री
स्पेन सिंपली अब मैं क्या करता हूं
इसको ये रहा केस 14 देखो केस 14 तक हम गए
और मुझे लगता है कि अब हो गया एंड यह रहा
यह देखो इतने यहां पर केस थे केस था उसके
बाद हमें केस को क्या करना पड़ेगा क्लोज
भी करना पड़ेगा डन अब यहां तक केस कंप्लीट
हो गया केस 14 तक देन मैं चलता हूं एक बार
यह रहा इसके एंड में चलता है और केस को
क्लोज करने के लिए मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा
नेक्स्ट लाइन में जाना है उसके बाद क्या
करना है केस को क्लोज भी करना है केस कहां
पर लिखा हुआ
है ये रहा आई थिंक दिस इज द राइट को क्लोज
करने ई एस ए सी देन अब मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं अभी इसके बेसस पर मैंने क्या कर
लिया डिसाइड तो कर लि कौन सी कंट्री के
अंदर है अब मैं इसका आउटपुट सबसे लास्ट
में परफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं क्योंकि
सेलेक्ट करने के बाद एकको उसके बाद मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं डॉलर एकको डॉलर सीटी एकको
डॉलर
सीटी डॉलर
सीटी इज इन डॉलर कंट्री
डॉलर डॉलर कंट्री देन इसको क्लोज कर दिया
उसके बाद मैं इसको क्या ब्रेक करूंगा
ब्रेक क्यों करूंगा क्योंकि आपको मैंने
पहले बता था जब सिलेक्ट कमांड को हम यूज
करते हैं क्योंकि ये कंटिन्यू चलता रहता
है लेकिन मैं चाहता हूं कि मेरा जब मैंने
एक बार ऑप्शन सेलेक्ट कर लिया ऑप्शन का
मुझे आउटपुट आया ब्रेक कर जाए मतलब एग्जिट
कर जाए उधर से ही बार-बार उस ऑप्शन में
लूप ना करता र करता रहे ये तो इस तरीके से
हमने क्या कर दिया ये अपना कोड लिख लिया
मैंने अगर आपको नहीं दिखा रहा मैं इसको
थोड़ा सा जूम आउट कर देता हूं ये
रहा देखो ये रहा पूरा पूरा कोड इतना हमने
लिखा इतना हमने कोड लिखा ये रहा बिल्कुल
अब इसको मैं क्या क आपको रन करके दिखा रहा
हूं फिर से मैं जूम कर देता हूं आपके
सामने य कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स अब मैं
क्या है तो मैं क्या कर सीच मोड देन मैं
क्या करता हूं सीटी
744 744 और सीटी ड एस सटी एस ट एटर अब मैं
क्या करता
सीटी सटी हा सटी एस ही कर सिटी चेकर था ब
सटी कर दिया हमने चलो और ट एटर कर दिया
अभी आपके सामने ऑप्शन दे रहा भया देखो
आपको कौन सा सेलेक्ट करना है टोक्यो
मॉस्को लंदन दुबई व्हाट एवर फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं सिलेक्ट करता हूं 14 मैंने क्या कर
दिया 14 सिलेक्ट कर दिया और जैसे ही मैंने
क्या हिट एंटर ये रहा इसने क्या बोला पुणे
इज इन इंडिया देखो सिंपली अब यहां पर
एग्जिट भी कर दिया इसने क्योंकि वहां पर
ब्रेक था फिर से अगर मैं रन करता हूं इसको
नेक्स्ट मैं अगर सेलेक्ट करना चाहता हूं
मैंने सिलेक्ट किया फॉर
एग्जांपल सेवन नंबर सेवन सेलेक्ट किया
मैंने यह रही टर अभी आपका न्यूयॉर्क इज इन
यूएस न्यूयॉर्क इज इन यूएस नेक्स्ट फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर मैंने फिर से इसको रन किया
और एक बार सेलेक्ट करता हूं तो फर मैं फ
सेलेक्ट किया लो इज इन यूई यू एई तो इस
तरीके से क्या कर आपने एक सीटी चेकर
स्क्रिप्ट आपने अच्छे से बना ली तो मुझे
लगता है कि आप लोगों को यह जो के
स्टेटमेंट का केस था आपको समझ में आया
होगा और काफी इंटरेस्टिंग था और मुझे लगता
कि अब आपको केस स्टेटमेंट को कैसे यूज
करना है इफ एल्स की जगह ये आपको अच्छे से
पता चल गया होगा
बताइए यस या नो जितने भी लोग है
प्रेजेंटली प्लीज बता दीजिए किय समझ में
आया नहीं आया जो कोड मैंने लिखा य रहा मैं
कोड को आपको दिखाऊ य
रहा अ मैं जूम आउट करके दिखाता हूं आपको
य पूरा कोड य पूरा का पूरा कोड यह है जो
आपको स्क्रीन के सामने दिखाई दे रहा
है
य श बता दीजिए उसके बाद हम फदर नेक्स्ट उस
पर चलते
हैं नेक्स्ट टॉपिक
पर
गाइज आई एम वेटिंग फॉर योर
रिस्पांस
अगर मैं आप लोगों को एक चीज कहूं तो आपको
बुरी लगने वाली है बहुत बुरी गाइस अगर कोई
यहां टाइम पास करने के लिए है स्पेशली आज
की जो क्लास चल रही है उससे रिलेटेड आपका
कोई भी क्वेश्चंस ना हो अगर आप लोग इसमें
कोई इंटरेस्टेड नहीं है तो सिंपली क्या कर
सकते हो लेव करके जा सकते हो ठीक है यहां
पर आपका एथिकल हैकिंग कोर्स या यह बग
बाउंट क्या है कब से शुरू हो रहा है सारी
चीजें आपको अनाउंसमेंट मिल जाती है सारी
चीजें सीरिल में सीक्वेंस में चलेंगी अगर
आप अपने मतलब के लिए यहां पर आते हो कि बस
मुझे वही मिलना चाहिए अरवाज मुझे फर्क
नहीं पड़ता तो हमें भी फर्क नहीं पड़ता आप
य क्लास लीव कर सकते मुझे कोई फर्क नहीं
पड़ेगा आपका सीखने वाले सीखेंगे य पर
जिसको बेनिफिट होगा बेनिफिट लेगा अरवाज आई
हैव नो प्रॉब्लम क आपरे को कोई फीस
प्रोवाइड नहीं कर रहे ना कोई आपसे फीस ले
रहा
हूं क्लास लीव कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है यू कैन गो ना यू मे लीव नाउ नो इ चलो
हम करते नेक्स्ट टॉपिक कंटिन्यू करते वा
लप के बारे में तो मैं आपको ले चलता हूं
एक बस बोर्ड प चलो
नेक्स्ट चलो अब बात करने वाले हैं वाय लूप
वाई लूप को हम कब और कैसे य थोड़ा सा आपके
सामने नोट्स में लिख देता हूं ओके ताकि
आपको पता चल
जाए वाइल
लूप वाइल
लूप डब् एच आई
एल वाइल
लूप वाइ लूप देखो क्या
है वाइ लूप का मैं एक स्टेटमेंट लिखता हूं
कि वायल क्या करता है कि जब आपको किसी भी
एक एक्सस को बार-बार परफॉर्म करना है किसी
एक कंडीशन के बेस पर मतलब क्या है कि आप
सिंपली कह सकते हो
रिपीट इफ स्टेटमेंट्स
मतलब रिपीट स्टेटमेंट का मतलब क्या है कि
जब तक वो एक सर्टेन कंडीशन है वो ट्रू
रहेगी तब तक उसका जो कोड है अंदर का कोड
वो रन करता रहेगा जैसे ही वो स्टेटमेंट
फल्स हो जाएगी तो उसका जो अंदर का जो कोड
था जो एक्शन था वह क्या करने हो जाएगा
सिंपली बंद हो जाएगा कंटिन्यू रिपीट एक्शन
में नहीं चलेगा
तो तो वाइल लूप लिखता हूं देखो वा
लूप लूप
रन
रंस रन ओके रन ए सेट
ऑफ सेट ऑफ कमांड सेट ऑफ कमांड वाइल ए
सर्टेन
कंडीशन सर्टेन कंडीशन इज
ट सर्टेन कंडीशन इज ट
न न द
कंडीशन वन द कंडीशन आई थ वन द कंडीशन इज
नो लंगर
ट्रू
देन
द वायल
लूप एंड्स
एंड
द सेल
कंटिन्यूज
कंटीन्यूअस कंटीन्यूअस सेल कंटीन्यूअस
स्पेलिंग क्या
है सी ओ
एन टी आई ओ यू एस
कंटीन्यूअस
प्रोसेसिंग प्रोसेसिंग द रेस्ट ऑफ द कोड
देखो क्या है कि जहां पर वायल लूप यूज
किया गया है तो वहां पर एक कंडीशन मेंशन
रहेगी कंडीशन या टेक्स्ट कंडीशन भी हो
सकती है या कोई भी कंडीशन होती है कोई भी
कमांड की कंडीशन होती है जब तक वाइल लूप
की कंडीशन ट्रू रहेगी तब तक वो क्या करर
कोड को रन करता रहेगा और जैसे ही वो
कंडीशन फुलफिल हो जाएगी फाल्स हो जाएगी तो
वो कंडीशन उसके अंदर जो कोड था रन होना
बंद हो जाएगा उसके बाद नेक्स्ट कोड जो
होगा वाइल लूप के बाद में जो भी होगा वो
रन करेगा रेस्ट ऑफ द कोड ये सिंपल वायल
लूप का मतलब आपको समझ में आगा वाइल लूप
रंस ए सेट ऑफ कमांड्स वाइल ए सर्टेन
कंडीशन इज ट्रू व्हेन द कंडीशन इज नो
लोंगर ट्रू देन द वाय लूप एंड्स एंड द सेल
कंटिन्यू प्रोसेस इन द रेस्ट ऑफ द कोड
नेक्स्ट हम चलते हैं अब हम एग्जांपल के
साथ हमने स्टार्ट करते हैं मैं स्क्रीन को
क्लियर कर देता हूं नेक्स्ट करता हूं मैं
ननो उसके बाद हम क्या करते हैं वाल ड एस
के नाम से स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करते हैं सबसे
पहली मेरी लाइन क्या है सी बैंग लाइन और य
आपको रट गई होगी स बै लाइन मुझे यूज करना
ही करना है नेक्स्ट हम क्या करते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं आपको एक स्क्रिप्ट रन करके
दिखाता हूं वाइल के बेस पर लेकिन सबसे
पहले मैं क्या कर रहा हूं रीड कमांड का
यूज कर रहा हूं न प उसके बाद प्रोमट कर
रहा हूं और मैं क्या बोहा हूं यूजर
को
एंटर
योर नंबर एंटर योर नंबर उसके बाद मैं इसको
क्या स्पेस किया नेक्स्ट इसको मैं नम के
अंदर एक वेरिएबल इसकी वैल्यू को स्टोर
करूंगा नेक्स्ट मैं क्या कर रहा वाइल लूप
को यूज करने वाला हूं वाल वाइल को यूज
करेंगे उसके बाद यहां पर हम क्या करेंगे
इफ कंडीशन की तरह ही हम क्या करते हैं
कंडीशन मेंशन करते हैं य पर तो य पर हम
टेस्ट कंडीशन भी मेंशन करते हैं कुछ भी
मेंशन कर क्या टेस्ट कंडीशन को मेंशन कर
टेस्ट कंडीशन मेंशन कैसे करते हैं जो
स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट है हर एक ओपनिंग
स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट के बीच में क्लोजिंग
स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट स्पेस होना चाहिए उसके
बीच में आप कंडीशन मेंशन करते हो तो मैं
डॉलर नम लिख रहा हूं यहां पर डॉलर नम उसके
बाद हाइन जीटी ग्रेटर देन उसके बाद अगर 10
से अगर ग्रेटर देन है तो ही ये क्या करें
इस इसको रन करें इसके अंदर के कोड को तो
यहां पर इसको कंडीशन जब आपने डिफाइन कर दी
य आपने इसको क्या कर दिया क्लोज कर दिया
यहां तक क्या कंडीशन डिफाइन हो वाइल लूप
उसके बाद कंडीशन उसके बाद सेमीकलन मतलब
यहां पर कंडीशन खत्म होगई उसके बाद आपको
क्या करना है वहां पर इफ कंडीशन के साथ आप
डू न यूज करते तो यहां पर आप यूज करोगे डू
डू मतलब अब इसके अंदर अगर ये ट्रू हो तो
इसके अंदर जो कोड आपको रन करना है हां
लेकिन एक चीज बताऊं वाइल लूप को अगर जब
यहां पर क्या है वाइल लूप भी एक कंपाउंड
कमांड है कंपाउंड कमांड रिजर्व से स्टार्ट
हुई अगर इसको स्टार्ट हो क्लोज भी करना हो
क्लोज करने के लिए हम क्या यूज करते हैं
यहां प डन यूज करते हैं डन और इसके बीच
में हम क्या करेंगे कोड रन करेंगे इसके
बीच में हम क्या करें कोड रन करें देखो
वाइल लूप से स्टार्ट वाइल वर्ड रिज वर्ड
से स्टार्ट हुआ यहां पर कंडीशन मेंशन किया
कंडीशन क्लोज कर दिया देन डू डू का यहां
पर आप सेल को बता रहे कि इसके बाद क्या
करना है जो कोड दिया हु ना यहां पर जो कोड
लिखोगे ये कोड एजू कर अगर ये ट्रू हुआ और
इसके बाद डन का मतलब ये क्या है ये वाइ
लूप की जो स्टेटमेंट है कंडीशन है आपकी
खत्म हो गई तो यहां पर मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं सिंपली एकको कर रहा हूं और आपको दिखा
रहा हूं एकको डॉलर नम एकको डॉलर नम उसके
बाद मैं क्या कर एक बार ओके हां चल जाएगा
एकको डॉलर नम देन सिंपली मैंने क्लोज कर
दिया इसको कंट्रोल एस और कंट्रोल एक्स अब
एक चीज देखिए आप एक चीज सोचो कि यहां पर
हो क्या रहा है मैं आपको बताता हूं चलो एक
बार देखो यहां पर हो क्या रहा है जैसे
यूजर ने कोई भी नंबर पुट किया पर फॉर
एग्जांपल यूजर ने पुट किया 15 नंबर तो
यहां पर क्या आ जाएगा 15 तो 15 क्या
ग्रेटर दन 10 से यस ग्रेटर दन 10 तो मतलब
ये ट्रू हो गया डू आपको क्या करना है एकको
करना है 15 अब वाई लूप में हुआ क्या देखो
यहां पर जो नम वेरिएबल था इसकी वैल्यू 10
है तो 10 ही रहेगी जैसे ही फिर से वालू
में क्या करता फिर सेय अगेन इसी पर जाएगा
यहां पर चेक करेगा इस कंडीशन में फिर से
चेक करेगा भैया जो नम वैल्यू है क्योंकि
अभी तक 10 नहीं है क्योंकि इसके अंदर 10 आ
गया ये एक बार रन कर दिया उसके बाद यहां
पर गया वैल्यू फिर 10 आ गई ओके फिर 10 है
फिर ये लूप रन कर फिर कर दिया को फ फिर से
गया यहां पर चेक किया कंडीशन को ये तब तक
चेक करता र जब तक कंडीशन ट्रू ना फाल्स ना
हो जाए तो य पर नम वेरिएबल फिर क्या है ही
है क्योंकि यहां पर हमने वैल्यू को ना तो
कम किया है ना ही ज्यादा किया है तो तब तक
य क्या करता रहेगा ये ये जब तक ट्रू रहेगा
तब तक इसको क्या करता रहेगा रन करता रहेगा
यहां पर कंडीशन ट्रू हुई फिर से इसको
प्रिंट किया फिर से 15 आया क् 15 ना तो कम
हो रहा है ना ज्यादा हो रहा फिर से 15 फिर
ऐसे ही ये क्या है
इनफाइनों कि ये अभी बंद होगा नहीं इससे
नीचे जो भी कोड होगा ना ये वाले ये कोई भी
कोड एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होगा यहां जो कोड
क्योंकि जब तक ये फॉल्स नहीं होगा तब तक
ये वाले कोड एग्जीक्यूट होंगे ही नहीं तो
अब मैं इसको कंट्रोल ए कक करके दिखाता हूं
और इसके बाद अगर सीच मोड देन सीच
मोड 744 उसके बाद लड ए वाल ड एस ये रहा अब
मैं इसको क्या करता हूं रन करता हूं फल ड
एस को क्या करता हूं ये रहा और हीट एंटर
कर दिया मैंने एंटर योर नंबर मैंने लिखा
15 चलो और जैसे ट एंटर करूंगा देखो 15 15
चल ही रहा है क्योंकि ये इनफा लूप में य
रोकने के लिए कंट्रोल एक्स करना पड़ेगा
मुझे कंट्रोल
सी इसको कंट्रोल सी करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि
इनफा चला काफी दे तक चला प्रोसेसिंग पावर
भी लेगा हो सकता है कि आपका सिस्टम हैंग
कर जाए तो अगर आपको इनफा लूप से इसको क्या
करना है बंद करना है तो उसको क्या करना
पड़ेगा आपको उस कंडीशन को फॉल्स करना होगा
और कंडीशन को फॉल्स मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं
कंडीशन को फॉल्स करने के लिए मेरे पास एक
ही तरीका है कि इसकी वैल्यू को मुझे हर
बार कम करना होगा तभी ये कंडीशन क्या
करेगी फाल्स होगी अदर वाइज ये इनफा लूप जा
अबब मैं क्या कर रहा हूं यहां पर जब मैंने
एग्जीक्यूट किया ओके देन ये रहा ये रहा
एंटर नेक्स्ट अब मैं क्या कर रहा हूं अगर
मुझे इसकी वैल्यू कम करना तो मुझे
अर्थमेटिक किसका यूज करना पड़ेगा
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन का यूज करना पड़ेगा
तोब मैं क्या कर रहा हूं नम नम इक्वल टू
अब हर बार में इसके क्या करूंगा अब
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन कैसे यूज करते हैं
डबल ये रहा ऐसे अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन आप
यूज करते इसके अंदर ये सिंपली अब मैं यहां
लिख रहा हूं डॉलर नम डॉलर नम माइनस व मैं
इसमें से एक हर बार माइनस वन करूंगा अब
यहां पर हो क्या रहा है मैं आपको बताता
हूं यहां पर आया एंटर किया 15 15 ग्रेटर
दन 10 है यस तो एक को कर दिया 15 अब अब
यहां आने के बाद क्या हुआ नम की वैल्यू
क्योंकि नम एक वेरिएबल था नम वेरिएबल की
वैल्यू क्या होगी यहां पर 15 थी 15 माइव
14 रह गई तो अब ये फिर से जाएगा इसके पास
ल के पास ओ चेक कि 14 यस फिर 13 यस 12 यस
11 यस और 10 आया अब 10 क्या इक्वल है
ग्रेटर देन तो नहीं है ये होगी फॉल्स
फॉल्स होते ही ये कंडीशन खत्म उसके बाद
फर्द कोड एग्जीक्यूट करेगा अब मैं इसको
क्या करता हूं कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल एक्स अब
मैं आपको रन करके दिखाता हूं
रहा अभी इसके अंदर मैं लि 15 जैसे 15 लिखा
मैंने ये आ गया 15 14 13 12 11 ओके कितना
फास्ट किया मैंने जैसे अग इसके अंदर फिर
से मैंने क्या किया अगर मैंने 50 लिखा
देखो ये रहा बिल्कुल इतना फास्ट कर रहा है
क्योंकि अभी तक हमने इसमें कुछ भी स्लीप
मोड उसमें डिले नहीं दिया लेकिन कंटिन्यू
इतना फास्ट रन कर रहा है ये अब ये रहा लड
एस फिर से दिया मैंने लिखा 11 ये रहा 11
ही आ गया उसके बाद क्लोज तो इस तरीके से
क्या करता है आपका वाइल लूप काम करता है
आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट की स्टेटस जो भी आपने
बोला क्योंकि देखो क्या है यार तुम्हारा
मुझे आई डोंट नो कि तुम फर्स्ट हो क्योंकि
रियल नाम से तो आप लोग आते नहीं तो अब
हमें प्रॉब्लम यह होती है कि हम कंटिन्यू
कंटेंट डिलीवरी करते हैं हाई लेवल कंटेंट
डिलीवरी करते हैं लेकिन हमारे कंटेंट से
रिलेटेड कोई कुछ पूछता ही नहीं फालतू के
सवाल रहते हैं यह कब आएगा वो कब आएगा और
आपको पता है कि हमारे नेक्स्ट अपकमिंग
चीजें आने वाली होती है ना वो तो या तो
मीम्स में आ जाती है या हम अनाउंसमेंट
करवा देते हैं आने से पहले या हमारा क्या
है कि अगर आप नए हो तो टेलीग्राम ग्रुप है
टे ग्रा ग्रुप में जाइए जवाइन कीजिए और
वहां पर हम क्या करते हैं ना पोल रन करते
रहते हैं कि और वो पोल क्या होता है
नेक्स्ट अपकमिंग कुछ 10 टू 15 डेज के अंदर
एक नया कोर्स आने वाला था उसका अपकमिंग
कोर्स का रहता है व तो अगर आपको अ लगाम
सॉरी फॉर ट
बट हमें क्या ना कि जो ऐसे क्वेश्चन आते
है ना थोड़ा सा लगता कि हम कंटेंट ली करते
ये कंटेंट का क्वेश्चन नहीं और उसको हम
आपको आंसर करें व भी इन इन बिटवीन सेशन दि
न राइट टाइम क्योंकि आप अपने लिए पूछ रहे
हो बट क्या कि जो बाकी है जिनके लिए इस
कंटेंट के वैल्यू उनका तो क्या है कि
वीडियो में थोड़ा टाइम वेस्ट होगा ना वो
फिर आएंगे नहीं बोला क्या फालतू क्वेश्चन
पूछते रहते हैं ट्स वा आईम सॉरी फट तो अगर
आपको य सवाल पूछने होते हैं तो जॉइन
टेलीग्राम ग्रुप एंड आस्क देयर व्ट आर योर
क्वेश्चन ओके तो नेक्स्ट हम बात करते हैं
यह तो मैंने क्या बताया आपको वाय लूप के
बारे में बता दिया वाय लूप कैसे काम करता
है अभी यह तो क्या वाइ लूप सिंपल वाल लूप
था अभी मैं आपको वाइ लूप में एक
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज बताता हूं इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज क्या है कि देखो क्या होता है कि आपने
एक चीज देखो ये रहा मैंने क्या किया एल एस
किया आउटपुट क्या आया ये अगर मैंने क्या
किया एल एस हान एल कर दिया आउटपुट मेरा
कैसे आया यह रहा आउटपुट मेरा यह आया मतलब
क्या पहले आउटपुट ऐसे आ रहा था अभी आउटपुट
ऐसे आया चलो मैंने क्या किया एल एस हाइन
एल ए और कर दिया अब मेरा आउटपुट और भी कुछ
चेंज हो देख डॉट वाली फाइल आ गई तो भैया
जो आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा एलस वाली चीज
एल एस हाइन एल हाइन ए ये सब चीज क्या है
यह क्या है ऑप्शंस है किसी भी एक
स्क्रिप्ट के किसी भी प्रोग्राम्स के
ऑप्शंस है और ऑप्शंस के बेस पे कोड लिखे
हुए हैं या एक्शंस लिखे हुए हैं टास्क
लिखे हुए हैं जो जो ऑप्शन आप सेलेक्ट करते
हो उस ऑप्शंस के बेस पर क्या होता है आपका
टास्क परफॉर्म होता है और आपका आउटपुट
आपके स्क्रीन के सामने आते हैं तो यह
एक्चुअल में बैस के अंदर ये ऑप्शंस कैसे
यूज कर सकते हो कि आप भी खुद की एक ऐसी
स्क्रिप्ट लिख है ताकि जैसे कि ए मैप यूज
करते हो ए मैप में जब भी आप ऑप्शंस करते
हो या किसी ऑप्श के साथ आप आर्गुमेंट भी
देते हो तो वो चीजें काम कैसे कर रही है
आप भी चाहते हो कि मैं अपना कोई खुद का
टूल बना रहा हूं खुद का कोई स्क्रिप्ट रन
कर रहा हूं मैं भी अपने स्क्रिप्ट के साथ
ऑप्शन देना चाहता हूं यूजर्स को और उस
ऑप्शन के अकॉर्डिंग वो एक्शन परफॉर्म हो
और उसका उसका आउटपुट उसकी स्क्रीन पर मिले
अब भी आपनी ऐसे स्क्रिप्ट बनाना चाहते हो
तो ऐसा काम करने के लिए आपको एक कमांड का
यूज करना पड़ता है उसका नाम है गट ओटी गेट
ऑप्स गेट ऑप्स गेट ओ पीटीएस ठीक है गेट
ऑप्स यूज करते हैं उस कमांड का नाम वह
क्या करती है कि उसके अंदर यह ऑप्शन हम
मेंशन करते हैं और वह क्या करती है उसे
नहीं है बाकी फिर जो कमांड के बाद में यह
यहां पर कोई भी आर्गुमेंट दो आप उससे मतलब
नहीं है अगर गेट ऑप्स के अंदर आपने जो जो
ऑप्शन दिए उसको उन्हीं से मतलब है वो क्या
करती है वो यहां से जो कमांड आर्गुमेंट है
ना यहां पर देखती है कि आप कौन सा ऑप्शन
प्रोवाइड कर रहे हो और उस ऑप्शन को अपने
अंदर चेक करती है कि हां क्या जो ऑप्शंस
यह चाहता है स्क्रिप्ट के साथ जो यूज करना
है कोड के अंदर जो यूज करना है क्या इसने
जो यूजर्स है इसने वही ऑप्शन दिया वही
ऑप्शन दिया तो ये क्या करता है उसके बेसिस
पर आपका एक्सेस परफॉर्म कर देता है अगर
वाइज अगर आपने वो ऑप्श दिया नहीं तो उसे
उससे कोई मतलब नहीं है ना वो कोई एरर देगा
एरर हां एरर देगा अगर आपने उसके लिए कोड
लिखा हुआ तो नहीं तो उसे फालतू आर्गुमेंट
से कोई मतलब जो आपने मेंशन किए वही एलएस
हान एल है एलएस के बाद अगर मैं हान जड यूज
कर लूंगा इट डंट मैटर कुछ नहीं इनवैलिड
ऑप्शन ओके मतलब ये कोई ऑप्शन ही नहीं है
क्योंकि उन्होने अ डिफाइन कर रखा है लेकिन
उन ऑप्शंस को हम यूज करने के लिए हम हाइन
के साथ यूज करेंगे इन आर्गुमेंट जो यहां
पर कमांड लाइ आर्ग जो ऑप्शन यूज कर उनको
हम हान के साथ यूज कर तो हम इनको कैसे यूज
कर सकते हैं अपनी क किसी भी स्क्रिप्ट के
अंदर मैं आपको सिखाता हूं चलो हम चलते हैं
अबकी बार अभी मैं क्या करू एक एग्जांपल है
एक स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करूंगा टेंपरेचर
कन्वर्ट एक स्क्रिप्ट मेरी उसके एग्जांपल
के साथ आपको समझाने वाला हूं स्कप में
बेसिकली हम करने क्या वाले हैं कि
हम फारेनहाइट को सेल्सियस में कन्वर्ट
करने वाले हैं और सेल्सियस की वैल्यू को
फारेनहाइट में कन्वर्ट करने वाले हैं बेस
ऑन द बेसिस ऑफ कमांड लाइन ऑप्शंस या आपके
जो स्क्रिप्ट के जो ऑप्शन है उसके आधार पर
हम कैसे करेंगे मैं क्या कर रहा हूं नैनो
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
एक म प टम उसके बाद कन्वर्टर कन्वर्टर
एस किया मैंने देन उसके बाद सी ब लाइन
प्रोवाइड कर रहा स ब लाइन मेंशन करता हूं
देन बिन और बेस य पर मैंने मेंशन किया बिन
और बेस नेक्स्ट अब बात करते हैं हम सबसे
पहले अब मुझे क्या करना है मुझे ऑप्शन
देने है यू को उसके बेस पर टास्क परफॉर्म
करने है ना भैया मुझे ऑप्शन दे ब टास्क
उसके लिए यूज करूंगा गेट ऑप्शन गेट ऑप्स
कमांड होती है इसका मैं यूज करूंगा गेट
ऑप्स ओके नेक्स्ट गेट ऑप्स यहां मेंशन कर
दोगे देन स्पेस के बाद आपको क्या करना है
डबल कोट के अंदर वो ऑप्शन मेंशन करोगे जो
आप यूजर्स को देना चाहते हो या जो आप जो
ऑप्शंस को यूजर यूज करेगा उसके बेसिस पर
आप आउटपुट अपना एक्शन परफॉर्म करोगे
फायरनेट के लिए मैं एफ यूज कर रहा हूं
सेल्सियस के मतलब के लिए सी यूज कर रहा
हूं जैसे ही आपका यूजर एफ यूज करेगा इसका
मतलब मुझे क्या करना है फारेनहाइट से
सेल्सियस में कन्वर्ट करना है अगर आपका
यूजर ऑप्शन सी यूज करेगा तो आपका क्या है
सेल्सियस टू फ नाइट में कन्वर्ट करना है
ओके देन ये इतना इतना ये हो गया अब कई बार
क्या होता है कुछ ऐसे ऑप्शंस होते हैं
जिनके खुद के आर्गुमेंट होते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल कई बार आपने देखा होगा कि किसी
भी कमांड के साथ आप क्या करते हो हाइ फन
यू करके उसके बाद यूआरएल मेंशन करते हो
मतलब क्या हाइन य तो ऑप्शन है लेकिन उसको
भी एक आर्गुमेंट चाहिए उस टास्क को
परफॉर्म करने के
लिए वही चीज हम यहां पर भी कर सकते हैं कि
मैं चाहता हूं कि अब ए और सी तो चलो मैं
बता दिया य को आप फारेनहाइट को सेल्सियस
में कन्वर्ट कि ऑप्शन यूज़ करना है सी को
सेल्सियस से फारेनहाइट में कव सी ऑप्शन
करना है लेकिन मुझे क्या करना है मुझे
यूजर से भी आर्गुमेंट चाहिए कि यूजर मुझे
बोले कि मुझे इतने फेनड को सेल्सिस में
कन्वर्ट करना है या इतने सेल्सिस को फाइट
में कन्वर्ट करना है उसके लिए मुझे क्या
करना है मतलब जो आप ऑप्शंस है उसको भी
आर्गुमेंट चाहिए तो उसके लिए आपको क्या
करना पड़े यहां पर कॉलन यूज़ करना पड़ेगा
और दोनों के आगे कॉलन यूज़ करना जिसके लिए
आपको आर्गुमेंट का यूज़ करना है उसके लिए
आप कॉलन यूज करोगे अगर आप आर्गुमेंट यूज
नहीं करना इस ऑप्शंस के बाद तो आप क्या है
कॉलन यूज नहीं करोगे अब देन अब हो तो ये
ये तो हो गया कि गेट ऑप्स क्या करेगा कि
आपके स्क्रिप्ट के बाद ऑप्शन चेक करेगा कि
जो ऑप्शंस एफ और सी ऑप्शन चेक करेगा अगर
एफ और सी ऑप्शन आपके यूजर्स ने प्रोवाइड
किए हैं तो क्या करेगा ये फर्द एक्शन
परफॉर्म करेगा ये एफ और सी को मैच करेगा
देन उसके बाद मुझे क्या चाहिए कि भैया
मुझे एक्शन परफॉर्म करने है ठीक है ये
सिलेक्शन कर ले कमांड लाइंड आर्गुमेंट में
चेक कर रहा है मुझे अब क्या करना है इसके
ऊपर मुझे एक्शंस भी परफॉर्म करने है अब
मुझे एक्शंस परफॉर्म करने है तो मुझे क्या
करना पड़ेगा एक वेरिएबल लेना पड़े क्योंकि
वेरिएबल के अंदर इन वैल्यू को स्टोर भी
करवाऊंगी ना मैं ए और सी को तभी तो मैं
फर्द उसके ऊपर क्या कर सकता हूं अपने
टास्क परफॉर्म कर सकता हूं अपने एक्शन
परफॉर्म कर सकता हूं क्योंकि वेरिएबल के
बेस पे ही हम टास्क परफॉर्म कर पा रहे हैं
इनकी डायरेक्ट वैल्यू तो मैं यूज नहीं कर
सकता तो मैं क्या कर सकता हूं फिर उसके
बाद मुझे क्या करना है इसके लिए एक
वेरिएबल का नाम डिफाइन करना है मैं यहां
पर ऑप्ट वेरिएबल का नाम डिफाइन कर दिया
चलो इतना हो गया अभी जो गेट ऑप्स है ना यह
काम कैसे करता है ना गेट ऑप्स की एक
प्रॉब्लम है जैसे ही फर्स्ट टाइम यह रन
करेगा गेट ऑप्स तो ये क्या करेगा फर्स्ट
ऑप्शन चूज कर लेगा और उसको चेक करेगा कि
यह दिया नहीं दिया यह सेकंड नहीं देखेगा
उसके बाद जैसे ही सेकंड टाइम नेक्स्ट टाइम
इसको रन करो ना गेट ऑप्स को तो ये क्या
करेगा फर्स्ट ऑप्शन प नहीं जाएगा सीधा
नेक्स्ट ऑप्शन हो जाएगा सी के ऊपर देन
उसके बाद उसको चेक करेगा उसके बेस पर
चलेगा ऐसे काम करता है मतलब एक बार में
दोनों ऑप्शन इस को एक्सेस नहीं करता ये
क्या करता है जितनी टाइम्स आप रन करते हो
हर एक बार में क्या नेक्स्ट ऑप्शन ऑप्शन
पे चला जाता है पहला वा जो ऑप्शन था उसके
वजह नेक्स्ट ऑप्शन प चलाता है फर्स्ट टाइम
जब रन किया तो एफ ऑप्शन ऑप्शन चूज किया
इसने सेकंड टाइम ज इसको रन किया तो इसने
डायरेक्टली सीधा सी ऑप्शन किया ना कि एफ
ऑप्शन ये ऐसे काम करता है तो मुझे अब एक
काम करना है कि मुझे तो स्क्रिप्ट ऐसी रन
करनी है कि मुझे दोनों ऑप्शंस को यूज करना
है ऐसा तो नहीं कि एक ही ऑप्शन यूज करना
होगा क्या बता उस टाइम पर रन करते वक्त
आपके यूजर ने प सेलेक्ट किया और ये सी
सेलेक्ट कर ले तो यह काम करने के लिए मुझे
क्या दोनों को एक साथ एक्सेस करना है एक
साथ एक्सेस करना है या फ्लेक्सिबल देनी है
मुझे क्या करना होगा इसको इसी की जो
यूटिलिटी है इसी जो काम करने का तरीका है
ये क्या करता है कि फर्स्ट टाइम रन करेगा
फर्स्ट ऑप्शन सेकंड टाइम रन क्या नेक्स्ट
ऑप्शन अगर उससे ज्यादा और ऑप्शन तो उसपे
जाएगा ठीक है तो अगर ऐसा इसकी फ्लेक्सिबल
है तो चलो मैं इसको कर सकता हूं ना मैं
इसको वाइल लूप के अंदर डाल दूंगा मैं क्या
करूंगा इसको वाइल लूप की कंडीशन बना दूंगा
वाइल लूप की क्या करूंगा कंडीशन बना दूंगा
कंडीशन कमांड बना दूंगा अब जब वाई लूप की
अगर मैं इसको कंडीशन कमांड बना सकता हूं
तो वाई लूप में क्या है जब तक ट्रू रहेगा
तब तक आपके टास्क परफॉर्म होंगे जैसे ही
फाल्स होगा मतलब ए और सी में से उसके बाद
कोई भी ऑप्शन परफॉर्म नहीं किया उसने ठीक
है तो क्या होगा यहां पर कंडीशन फाल्स
होगी और फाल्स होगी तो इसका मतलब ल से आउट
हो जाएंगे हम तो ये काम मैं कर सकता हूं
इजली और एक और चीज ध्यान रखना अगर ये ऑप्ट
वेरिएबल है क्योंकि ये वेरिएबल है इसके
अंदर ये क्या करता है अगर ए और c के यूज
ने कुछ भी दिया कुछ भी दिया खाली जोड़
दिया तो ये क्या करता है अगर ए और सी
वेरिएबल नहीं है तो यह नहीं दिए तो यहां
पर क्या करेगा इसके अंदर य क्वेश्चन मार्क
को स्टोर कर लेता है अगर वैलिड ऑप्शन है
तो यह इस वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर कर लेगा
अपने वेरिएबल के अंदर अगर वैलिड ऑप्शन
नहीं दिया आपकी यूजर ने तो य क्या
क्वेश्चन मार्क स्टोर करेगा और क्वेश्चन
मार्क मतलब इनवैलिड ऑप्शन अब मैं क्या
करता हूं इसको वाइ लूप के अंदर ऐड करता
हूं सिंपली तो वा लूप ऐड करने के लिए देन
अब ये इसकी कंडीशन है लकी की ये दो ऑप्शन
सेलेक्ट करने है इसके बेस पर मुझे क्या
करना है टास्क परफॉर्म करने है तो अब ये
क्या मेरी कंडीशन है तो कंडीशन मेरी खत्म
होगी मुझे इस कमांड को ही कंडीशन डाल दी
इसकी वल की अब कंडीशन खत्म ई नेक्स्ट मुझे
क्या करना डू करना था डू करना देन उसके
बाद डन इसलिए करना है क्योंकि मुझे वा लूप
को क्लोज करना है डन इसलिए करना मुझे वा
लूप को क्लोज करना है डन कर लिया मैंने
नेक्स्ट मैं क्या करूंगा अभी जब मैंने वाल
को क्लोज करना है तो मुझे स्क्रिप्ट लिखनी
है मेरे पास क्या पहले से ही फार्मूला है
मैंने इंटरनेट से निकाला हु है ताकि टाइम
वेस्ट ना हो तो अब मुझे क्या करना है देखो
अब मुझे एफ और सी जो ऑप्शंस है इसके बेस प
कंडीशन परफॉर्म करनी है तो कंडीशन परफॉर्म
करने के लिए मैं क्या करूंगा केस
स्टेटमेंट का यूज करूंगा केस स्टेटमेंट
उसके केस के अंदर आपको क्या करना है डबल
कोट डबल कोट के अंदर डॉलर उसके बाद मैं
यूज करने वाला ऑप्ट डॉलर ऑप्ट उसके बाद ये
हो गया नेक्स्ट इन डॉलर ऑप्ट और इन अब मैं
क्या करना मेरे पास दो केस है मेरे पास दो
केस है पहला तो केस क्या है मेरे पास ए एक
तो मेरे पास ये केस है नेक्स्ट मेरे पास
कौन सा केस है सी मेरे पास नेक्स्ट केस
क्या है मेरे पास सी है फाइट टू सेल्स
सेल्सियस फाइट अब मुझे क्या करना है चलो
इसके बेस प मैं क्या करना ह फेस लिखता हूं
रिजल्ट आ हां रिजल्ट रिजल्ट के अंदर मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं स्टोर एक वेरिएबल के
अंदर क्या वैल्यू स्टोर करना अब मैं क्या
कर इसके लिए पहले ही मैंने क्या किया हुआ
है एक इसका फार्मूला निकाला हुआ है कि
फारेनहाइट टू सेल्सियस कैसे कन्वर्ट होगा
तो मैं क्या करता हूं इसके लिए कमांड है
तो उसको मैं क्या करता हूं कमांड
सब्सीट्यूशन करता हूं उसकी जो वैल्यू आएगी
मैं उसको स्टोर कर लूंगा तो एकको उसके बाद
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं डब ये ये चलो ये डबल
कोट उसके बाद स्केल इक्वल टू 2
देन स्केल इक्वल टूटू चलो इसको स्केल
इक्वल टूटू इसको क्लोज किया देन मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं कॉमा कॉमा किया मैंने कॉमा देन
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं कॉमा उसके बाद फिर से
ब्रैकेट ओपन किया उसके बाद ब्रैकेट क्लोज
किया एक और उस ब्रैकेट के अंदर मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं यहां पर
डॉलर ऑफ्ट ए आरजी डॉलर ऑफ ए आरजी कर रहा
हूं उसके बाद नेक्स्ट मल्टीप्लाई उसके बाद
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
ना ना डिवाइड बाय 5 ना डिवा बा 5 ये मेरा
एक फार्मूला है नेक्स्ट देन मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं प्लस 32 प् 32 उसके बाद इसको
मैंने क्या कर दिया क्लोज कर दिया अभ ये
किसका क्लोजिंग है किसका देखना पड़ेगा
मुझे किसका क्लोजिंग है
ओके इसको क्लोज य नहीं करना स्केल को य पर
क्लोज नहीं करना य सिंपली किसका क्लोजिंग
था स्केल कमा देन इसके बाद य और उसके बाद
मैंको क्या कर जो भी आउटपुट आएगा इसको
पाइप करता हूं बीसी कमांड के अंदर उसके
बाद इसको क्या करता हूं क्लोज करता कमांड
सबट मेरा सिंपल कमांड सबट है और केट में
क्लोज करने के लिए यज करते अभी य पर अब आप
लोग बोलोगे सर य क्या
है यह कहां से आया प आर् क्या होता है
इसका मतलब होता है ऑप्शनल आर्गुमेंट मतलब
मैं आपको समझाता हूं अगर आपने क्या किया
हुआ है जो आपने गेट ऑप्स में जो ऑप्शन
सिलेक्ट किए हुए हैं जिन ऑप्शन के बेस पर
टास्क परफॉर्म करना चाहते हो जिस ऑप्शन के
बेस पर आप यूजर यूजर को सिलेक्शन देना
चाहते हो और यूजर ऑप्शन को चूज करें अगर
उन ऑप्शन में ऑप्शंस में क्या है
आर्गुमेंट देने हैं अगर वो ऑप्शंस क्या है
आर्गुमेंट से रिलेटेड है मतलब क्या है कि
आपको ऑप्शन यूज करना ऑप्शन के बाद आपको
आर्गुमेंट देना है तो क्या होता है बाय
डिफॉल्ट उस आर्गुमेंट की वैल्यू ऑप्ट जो
एक एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल होता है सिस्टम
डिमांड वेरिएबल होता है ऑप्ट आर्गुमेंट
इसके अंदर आके स्टोर होती है बाय डिफॉल्ट
अगर आपने यहां पर सिंपली एफ दिया हुआ होता
इसके साथ कोई भी आर्गुमेंट नहीं चाहिए
होता तो आपको फिर आपको ये यूज करने की
जरूरत नहीं होती एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल अब
आपको क्या है कि f के बाद आपको एक
आर्गुमेंट देना है वैल्यू देनी है
फारेनहाइट की जिसको कन्वर्ट करना है
सेल्सिस में इसलिए वो आर्गुमेंट की वैल्यू
बाय डिफॉल्ट ऑफ्ट आर्गुमेंट के अंदर आके
स्टोर हो जाती य पर वो वैल्यू आएगी जो ए
की वैल्यू होगी य बाय डिफॉल्ट होता है
आपको चिंता करने की जरूरत नहीं है नेक्स्ट
हम चलते नेक्स्ट लाइन में अब रिजल्ट इक्वल
टू एक और फ फर्मूला इसके लिए अलग है इसके
बाद यह क्लोज कर देता हूं नेक्स्ट एक को
देन मैं क्या करता हूं फिर से य है
स्केल एस
सल इक्वल
टू स्केल इक्वल टू कॉमा देन मैं क्या करता
हूं उसके
बाद स्केल इक्वल टू कॉमा
या ओके ओके कॉमन हैय आईम सॉरी फॉर ट
क्योंकि मैंने लिखा हु फार्मूला यह है
सेमीकलन य पर सेमीकलन है य रहा सेमीकलन
देन उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है देन उसके
बाद आपका क्या है यह
रहा
डॉलर ऑट ए आरजी आर्गुमेंट ऑट आर्गुमेंट
उसके बाद माइनस एजी माइनस
माइनस 32 देन उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है
यह इसको क्लोज करना है क्लोज किया उसके
बाद मल्टीप्लिकेशन करना है उसके बाद आपको
यह दोप उसके बाद 5 बाना 5 बाना य फर्मूला
डोंट री इसको समझने की जरूरत नहीं कि सर य
हो क्या रहा है कर क्या रहे हो डोंट वरी
ओके उसके बाद मैं इसको क्या करता हूं बीसी
कमांड के अंदर देता हूं बी कमांड अगर क्या
आएगा आपका अगर उसमें आता है पॉइंट्स में
आता है ओके तो ये रहा आपको बीसी कमांड के
अंदर आपने मेंशन कर दिया तो ये दो उसके
फार्मूला थे सेल्सियस टू फेरहाट कन्वर्ट
करने के लिए और फारेनहाइट टू सेल्सियस
करने के लिए ठीक है तो ये आपके मैंने आपने
दो ऑप्शन आपके दो फर्मूला मेंशन कर दिया
नेक्स्ट अभी के स्टेटमेंट को क्या करना है
क्लोज भी करना है तो इस सेक के स्टेटमेंट
मैंने क्या कर दिया क्लोज कर दिया अभी के
स्टेटमेंट को तो मैंने क्लोज कर दिया और
अभी ये रहा चलो वाई लूप का मैंने इसमें
रिजल्ट स्टोर हो जाएगा अभी क्या करूंगा जब
य जो भी ऑप्शन सेलेक्ट हो जाएगा इसका
रिजल्ट क्या है इसका जो आउटपुट रहेगा आर ई
एस ए यू एलटी एक मिनट आरई
एस अ
एस एलटी रिजल्ट इसके अंदर स्टोर हो जाएगा
अब मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं यहां पर अपना
आउटपुट लेना चाहता हूं मैं क्या करना चाता
एक करवाना चाहता हूं एकको उसके बाद
डॉलर रिजल्ट एक डॉलर यल ये चाहता हूं अभ
चाहता हूं जैसे ही यहां पर एफ सेलेक्ट
किया c सेलेक्ट किया उसके बेस पर एफ के
बेस पे यह टास्क परफॉर्म हो गया या स के
बेस पे टास्क परफॉर्म होगा यह एक बार
परफॉर्म हो गया क्योंकि एफ और सी के जो भी
सिलेक्शन किया उसके बाद क्या हो गई
नेक्स्ट टाइम क्या एफ सिलेक्शन हो गया एफ
के बाद क्या जाएगा नेक्स्ट c सी सिलेक्ट
किया नहीं तो उसके बाद फाल्स हो जाएगा
जैसे ही फाल्स हुआ उसके बाद आउट हो जाए
आउट होने के बाद रिजल्ट में जो आउटपुट
होगा आपका स्क्रीन पे शो हो जाएगा अब मैं
क्या करता हूं कंट्रोल s कंट्रोल x आपको
शो करता हूं नेक्स्ट मैं आपको अभी बताता
हूं यह
रहा यह रहा रन करके दिखाता हूं मैं सी मोड
देन आपका 744 उसके बाद आपका क्या है क्या
थाय अभी इसका नाम था
टेंपरेचर
टेंपरेचर ओके मम डट
एस
म डट एस ओके 744 उसके बाद मैं क्या करता
हूं ड एस को रन करता हूं उसके बाद मुझे
क्या करना चाहिए ड एस
ए ड ए उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है हाइन के
उसके ऑप्शन को यूज करने के लिए मुझे क्या
करना हो हाफ प्स में एफ उसके बाद मैं क्या
करना 20 लिखा मैंने 20 उसके बाद मैं क्या
कर ट एंटर कर दिया देखो
68.0 डिग्री सेल्सियस ओके अगर मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं सी की बजाय मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं यहां पर सी जाता हूं सी और 32 य
32 लिखा र जीरो आ गया अगर मैं 20 लिख दू
30 लिखता हूं तो यह रहा -
1.10 अभी हम यहां पर क्या लिखता हूं 20 ये
रहा - 6.4 तो इस तरीके से अगर यहां पर लिख
दिया आपने 50 यहा सी 59.90 अगर मैं यहां
पर क्या करता हूं ए एफ के साथ में क्या
आर्गुमेंट दे रहा हूं ये आर्गुमेंट कहां
पे जा स्टोर हो रहा आपके ऑफ्ट आर्गुमेंट
एनवायरमेंट वेरिएबल के अंदर उसके बेस आपका
टास परफॉर्म होहा हान f हान सी उसके बाद
आर्गुमेंट आपको देना है क्योंकि आपने वहां
पर मेंशन किया है ये इस कमांड के अंदर कौन
सी गेट कमांड के अंदर अभी मैं यहां 55
दिया चलो ले रहा
13100 आपका ये आ गया सेल्सियस टेंपरेचर तो
यह था आपका वल लू प्लस में क आप कमांड
लाइन आर्गुमेंट में ऑप्शन देके आपने
स्क्रिप्ट को ऑप्शन देके आप हर एक ऑप्शंस
के बेस पर कैसे टास्क परफॉर्म कर सकते हो
यह मैंने आपको सिखाया है कि गेट ऑप्स
कमांड का यूज करके कैसे आप कमांड लाइन
आर्गुमेंट में अपने यूजर को ऑप्शन दे सकते
हो उस ऑप्शन के बेस प अलग-अलग टास्क
परफॉर्म कर सकते सकते हो फ इन फ्यूचर कभी
भी आपको अपने खुद के टूल बनाने की जरूरत
पड़ेगी तो आपको क्या करना होगा इस
कांसेप्ट को यूज करना ही होगा मेरे पास एक
प्रोजेक्ट भी है असाइनमेंट भी है बट आप
लोगों को देने का कोई फायदा नहीं है बिकॉज
सबने छोड़ दिया आना तो आई एम सॉरी फॉर आई
विल नॉट गिव य द असाइनमेंट मैं क्या करर
हूं सिंपली आपको
फरदर क्या करने वाला हूं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में उसको सॉल्व करके दिखा दूंगा और फिर
फर्द हम कंटिन्यू चलते हैं तो मुझे लगता
नहीं है किसी को कोई डाउट हो क् कोई है
नहीं है क्लास में तो इट्स ओके अगर आपको
क्लास अच्छी लगी तो लाइक कीजिए सब्सक्राइब
कीजिए शेयर करना मत भूलिए अगर आप और कमेंट
बिल्कुल कीजिए हमारे लिए काफी हेल्पफुल
होता है तो अब मैं सेशन को एंड करता हूं
तो आज का सेशन इतना ही था तो बाय बाय गुड
नाइट टेक केयर